can be translated as the book of the
imminence of the way
or the book of the way and of how it
manifests itself in the world
or simply the book of the way
since it is already well known by its
chinese title
i have let that stand about lao tzu
its author there's practically nothing
to be said
he may have been an older contemporary
of confucius
551-479 bce
and may have held the position of
archive keeper in one of the petty
kingdoms of the time
but all the information that has come
down to us is highly suspect
even the meaning of his name is
uncertain the most likely
interpretations the old master or more
picturesquely
the old boy like an iroquois woodsman
he left no traces all he left us
is his book the classic manual on the
art of living
written in a style of gem-like lucidity
radiant with humor and grace
and large-heartedness and deep wisdom
one of the wonders of the world people
usually think of laozi as a hermit
a dropout from society dwelling serenely
in some mountain hut
unvisited except perhaps by the
occasional traveler arriving from a
sixties joke to ask
what is the meaning of life but it's
clear from his teachings
that he deeply cared about society if
society means the welfare of one's
fellow human beings
his book is among other things a
treatise on the art of government
whether of a country or of a child the
misperception may arise from his
insistence on wei wu
way literally doing not doing
which has been seen as passivity
nothing could be further from the truth
a good athlete can enter a state of body
awareness
in which the right stroke or the right
movement happens by itself
effortlessly without any interference of
the conscious will
this is a paradigm for non-action the
purest and most effective form of action
the game plays the game the poem
writes the poem we can't tell the dancer
from the dance less and less do you need
to force things
until finally you arrive at non-action
when nothing is done nothing is left
undone nothing is done because the doer
has wholeheartedly vanished into the
deed
the fuel has been completely transformed
into flame
this nothing is in fact everything
it happens when we trust the
intelligence of the universe
in the same way that an athlete or a
dancer trusts the superior intelligence
of the body
hence laozi's emphasis on softness
softness means the opposite of rigidity
and is synonymous with suppleness
adaptability
endurance anyone who has seen a tai chi
or aikido master doing not doing
will know how powerful this softness is
laozi's central figure is a man or woman
whose life is in perfect harmony with
the way things are
this is not an idea it is a reality
i have seen it the master has mastered
nature
not in the sense of conquering it but of
becoming
it in surrendering to the dow
in giving up all concepts judgments and
desires
her mind has grown naturally
compassionate
she finds deep in her own experience the
central truths of the art of living
which are paradoxical only on the
surface
that the more truly solitary we are the
more compassionate we can be
the more we let go of what we love the
more present
our love becomes the clearer our insight
into what is beyond good and evil
the more we can embody the good until
finally she is able to say
in all humility i am the dao
the truth the life
the teaching of the daodijin is moral in
the deepest sense
unencumbered by any concept of sin the
master doesn't see evil as a force to
resist
but simply as an opaqueness a state of
self-absorption
which is in disharmony with the
universal process
so that as with a dirty window the light
can't shine through
this freedom from moral categories
allows him his great compassion for the
wicked
and the selfish thus the master is
available to all people
and doesn't reject anyone he is ready to
use
all situations and doesn't waste
anything
this is called embodying the light
what is a good man but a bad man's
teacher
what is a bad man but a good man's job
if you don't understand this you will
get lost
however intelligent you are it is the
great
secret the listener will notice that in
the many passages where laozi describes
the master
i've used the pronoun she at least as
often as he
the chinese language doesn't make this
kind of distinction
in english we have to choose but since
we are all
potentially the master since the master
is
essentially us i felt it would be untrue
to present a male
archetype as other versions have
ironically
done ironically because of all the great
world religions
the teaching of laozi is by far the most
female
of course you should feel free
throughout the recording
to substitute he for she or vice versa
as to method i worked from paul karas's
literal version which provides english
equivalents
often very quaint ones alongside each of
the chinese ideograms
i also consulted dozens of translations
into english
german and french but the most essential
preparation for my work
was a 14 years long course of zen
training
which brought me face to face with laozi
and his true disciples and heirs
the early chinese zen masters with great
poetry
the freest translation is sometimes the
most faithful
we must try its effect as an english
poem dr johnson said
that is the way to judge of the merit of
a translation
i have often been fairly literal or as
literal as one can be with such a subtle
kaleidoscopic book as the dao de jing
but i have also paraphrased
expanded contracted interpreted
worked with the text played with it
until it became embodied in a language
that felt genuine to me
if i haven't always translated lao tzu's
words
my intention has always been to
translate his mind
describing the indescribable
teaching the unteachable pointing the
way
to the way what does lao tzu think he is
doing here
it can't be done no way
hence poetry poet and stand-up comedian
wrote he who talks doesn't know
he who knows doesn't talk that is what
lao tzu told us
in a book of five thousand words
if he was the one who knew how could he
have been such a blabber mouth
that's the problem with spiritual
teachers
they have to be blabber maths but their
words are
in the traditional buddhist metaphor
fingers
pointing at the moon if you watch the
finger
you can't see the moon how meticulous
the great masters had to be
a monk asked matsu why do you teach
mind is buddha matsu said
to stop a baby from crying
the monk said when the crying has
stopped what then
matsu said then i teach
not mind not buddha
the monk said how about someone who
isn't attached to either
matsu said i would tell him not beings
the monk said and what if you met a man
unattached to all things
what would you tell him matsu said
i would just let him experience the
great dao
in fact the truth is right before our
eyes
right under our noses so simple
that every child understands it and yet
as bankai said the farther you enter
into it
the deeper it is where is the way to the
way
what a question still
for complicated minds drastic measures
are needed
laotz's book was written as a response
out of grandmotherly kindness
according to the oldest biography lao
tzu lived for a long time
in the country of chu but seeing its
decline
he departed when he reached the frontier
the guard said since you are going away
sir could you write a book to teach me
the art of living
thereupon lao tzu wrote his book about
the tao
and departed this is legend
but it is an accurate description of the
way in which true teaching
happens he who knows doesn't talk
but words are no hindrance for him
he uses them as he would use gardening
tools
when someone asks he answers